You know, I, I, I agree
with you that I don't,
I don't necessarily think we're getting
stupider or dumber in this country or in
the world in general
because of the Internet,
but we're definitely getting weirder in
our perceptions of actual world events.
And I think, um, every time something
like mass shootings for instance,
like New Zealand, every time one of
these horrific tragedies takes place,
you see more and more division as I
watch people fight over it on Twitter,
people blaming leftwing people,
people blaming right wing people,
people trying to find some reason.
And this one is particularly disturbing
because it appears that at least one of
the guys, I don't know their names,
I don't know if they even released,
they withheld the names of
these guys who've done this.
I haven't seen the names.
I fought in it. One of them seems
like he's trolling. Like he,
he thanked Pewdie Pie and,
and said that Candace Owens was as big
as inspiration and he's doing that. Well,
I guess we could agree.
Some people are saying that that okay,
sign is a white power sign.
I know we had this dispute with
Tim Pool where he was saying,
I guess it is a game that some people
do play. What is it called, the game?
The look,
I don't know if there's an official name.
There's some game where if you look under
the table, you see someone doing that.
There are a lot of punch you or something.
Something stupid like that.
I saw the Steven Miller photo where
he's doing up his blazer and supposedly
doing the why, but that of that,
is that the evidence enough? No,
and there was a woman in court too that
was doing that where she had her hand
like this and people were saying that.
But that's what people are talking about
rather than, right. Which is ridiculous.
Like Ah, evidence, evidence.
But this guy in custody is clearly
making that symbol clearly.
So like, what is he, you know,
he's like some troll murderer,
some troll mass murderer,
and he's both,
he's both fucking with everybody.
And a cold blooded ruthless killer of
people that were praying. Yeah. I mean,
I think let's not lose sight of that.
You have to have some serious hatred to
walk into a mosque and gun down. Yeah.
He's a TTA people in seven people in
the other one. You know that's, yeah,
it's horrific across the board,
top to bottom. It's, it's horrific,
but it's also one of those things where
like we see so many of these now that
we're, we're starting to get numb.
Whether it's a a Jewish synagogue,
whether it's a, you know, a Muslim temple,
whether it's a gay club
where whether whatever it is,
it's like you see so many of these mass
murders now that it's just whether it's
a school or a movie
theater. I'd like, fuck man.
It's just it all,
like you were talking about when you
were filming the news and you're,
you're there,
you're watching the bullets fly by.
You hear them fly by your head and you
are just watching it through the Lens.
We are many, many, many,
many levels removed from that and we're
sitting here trying to figure out what
to do and we're there.
We're not where the bullets and the people
that are there where the bullets take
place.
They try to give you a description of
it and even they barely can comprehend
what happened.
But,
but also as you said,
we're going straight to the
argument about who to blame.
When did he follow and you
know, rather than, yes.
I mean if people spent as much time as
they spend arguing on Twitter at reading
[inaudible] I know people say fake news,
you know that there are people who you
can trust if they write a 10,000 word
piece on Syria for the New Yorker for
example, like you know that they're,
they're being fact check
and maybe it would be
better if there was a website where we
curated all of like the bulletproof,
that's terrible way to describe it,
but you know,
Lock Sa Rock solid
investigative journalism's
that are 100% ethical that you
could completely rely on for an
accurate assessment of what's happening.
Because it is difficult for
people and when people, they,
they rely on biased websites,
which many of them do,
whether it's biased to the left or bias
to the right, things get even more money.
And there's so many of them.
It's so easy to get,
so easy to reinforce your confirmation
bias, Wa whatever, you know,
whether it's left brain or right wing,
just find that website, read the comments.
These are my people.
They think like me.
And,
and especially now mean it used to be if
you were conservatively and then you'd
read the Wall Street Journal or
Liberal leading New York Times now,
no matter how far off the scale you are,
you can find a pretty professional
looking website. Yeah.
That we'll write a story backing up your
prejudice and people aren't looking at
the story thinking, okay, I'm gonna
find out what happened here. Yeah.
They're thinking, I know what my gut
feeling tells me I need to find a hit.
Not even a story. A headline. Yeah. That
justifies my gut feeling about this.
And that's as far as it seems to go.
Now,
you as a journalist,
as a person who risked their life
to bring this information to people,
how does this make you feel?
I mean,
is this part of the reason why you
needed to do that? MDME therapy,
not just the fact that you
were, you know, you're,
you really are without better useful,
without a better term shell
shocked. Right? I mean,
you're, you're that, that Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. You're there.
There's something that comes out
of that that's gotta be very,
very difficult to recover
from and overcome. Yeah.
But there's also the fact that you're
going over there and bringing this shit
back and it doesn't seem to,
people don't see to
you give a fuck. And that used to be what
kept you going is, is you thought like,
some of my work is going to
make some kind of difference.
And when that starts to fade and you
start to think that's not going to happen.
That's,
I'm sure your work makes
a lot of difference to the
people that pay attention to
it. That I think we're, we're
overwhelmed by bullshit.
I think it's everywhere. There's what
I mean bullshit. I mean like nonsense.
You know,
Kim Kardashians psoriasis is in the
front page of CNN or something like that.
You know what I mean? It's not nonsense
to her, but you know what I mean?
Like there's, there's stuff that
people are concentrating on.
It's like Jesus Christ,
I mean, yeah, one of our, one of our
docs, Hbo, um, if it got 4 million views,
I think that would be considered very
good viewing figures in the country of 360
million people. Yeah. Well
it's very difficult to do
get people to watch documentaries
on real world events.
You get them to watch documentaries on
like a sex call from Oregon or something
like that. Like wow. While country
that probably got 10 million. Yeah.
It's this, I don't know man. You know,
this New Zealand thing
really had me rattled. I,
and you know what is also strange,
people like seem to demand a response.
They demand,
um,
people in the public eye to
talk about it and you know,
say thoughts and prayers
or something like that.
But as soon as you say thoughts
and prayers, they'll say
they'll, it's impressive.
We've had that for years and
nothing's actually happened.
It's, yeah. Yeah. It's um,
it's very strict, but like
the, I don't know if they,
they're concerned that you're
not horrified. They want
to make sure you are like,
who the fuck isn't, like,
how could you not be,
I don't understand this or is
it just they're just frustrated,
confused themselves.
So just lashing out at any target
they can find or anyone they can find.
And also, you know, I mean, I know the
footage is available of, of, you know,
this guy's head cam as he,
as he shot everybody, but,
but footage like that has been widely
available for a long time now. Um,
and I think that's, that's had a massive,
nothing effect. I mean, you know, the,
the picture of the Syrian refugee
washing up on the beach, you know,
it felt like that was
going to have an effect.
It felt like that was the picture that
was really gonna gonna change things. No,
I'm not sure it then it might have for
a couple days. Yeah. And then more news,
you know, I mean, not, you know,
just to be not completely pessimistic
that when you're doing stuff for vice and
Hbo, you do get young people reaching
out to you and saying, oh, I had no idea.
I want to be a photographer or a doctor
or maybe that's an effect that's going
to be felt down the room. I don't
know. It feels like there are,
there is a generation of
people growing up thinking,
I'm not going to play by the normal set
of rules like I am going to actually try
and do something about this.
I think I really do believe
you do have an effect.
I think vice certainly has an effect.
I think a lot of this has an effect.
I think it's very difficult to feel that
effect if you're not experiencing it
personally. I mean to, to just look
out onto the landscape and say,
how much of an effect is this
having on people? It's hard.
Like where are you getting the
feedback from? How are you,
how are you gauging whether or not
this is changing people's perceptions?
Well, sometimes the feedback you
do get is is on Twitter we'll get,
a few lunatics will say, Oh, you
failed to do so. Then you think, wow,
we're really having no impact,
but I think that's an argument
for just not reading the comments.
There's a little bit of
that. And then, you know,
I had Renee to rest on recently and she's
done a lot of work covering all these
various, uh, Russian troll
farms and how they, uh,
so how they essentially
organize conflict online and,
you know,
the,
they set up these things where you have
like a pro Texas movement and they set
them up across the street from a pro
Muslim movement and they do it on purpose.
And then they have these pro
LGBT movement things online.
They organize to attack certain
people in certain groups,
diminish certain aspects and defied parts
of the Democratic Party. It's crazy.
Yeah. When you hear about shit like that
on top of all this, you're like, well,
okay, uh, just the, the actual news
itself is so difficult to disseminate.
It's so difficult to figure out what
should I pay attention to? What's real?
And then you have this kind
of shit happening on top
of that. You're like, Whoa,
whoa, Whoa, fuck. You know.